Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of the
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lobs, and
today I'm joined by a returned guest, Doctor Lars
Penke. He's full professor of biological personality Psychology at
the University of Gottingen, and today we're going to
explore the evolutory shift hypothesis, what it is and
Uh, studies that Dr. Pene and his collaborators have
been doing over the past few years to test
this hypothesis and the several different predictions that come
out of it. So, Doctor Pena, welcome back to
the show. It's great to see you again.
It's a pleasure to be here again.
So let's start. I mean, I think that we've
touched at least briefly on these hypotheses in our
first conversation, but I mean just for people who
might not be familiar with it and perhaps to
update. Some of what's been going on surrounding these
hypothesis in recent years. What is it really about
and what are the main predictions that people have
been putting forth that supposedly derived from it?
Yeah, so the ovulatory cycle shift hypothesis uh concerns
the female ovulatory cycle. So women emit steroid hormones
cyclically across their monthly ovulatory cycle, and that is
primarily related to reproductive functioning. So it's related to
Uh, the ripening and the release of the ovum
of the eel and, uh, its implementation, so it's
preparing for conception and pregnancy, and hormones are extremely
interesting molecules because they usually don't only have a
local effect but have effects all over the body
and that includes our brain and our psychology. And
therefore, there is a huge field of behavioral endocrinology
that is concerned with how hormones affect behavior and
that intersects very much with evolutionary psychology because always
when something is related to reproduction, then it is
close to biological functions related to evolution. The ovulatory
cycle shift hypothesis in particular is concerned with how
female psychology changes across the ovulatory cycle. And um
it's a plausible idea that it does, and there
have been over the years, many ideas what exactly
shifts. So in the very early days, there were
ideas, for example, that uh how women categorize people
into male and female and how much attention they
pay to whether somebody is male or female shifts
across the ovulatory cycle. There have been studies about
uh spatial perception across the ovulatory cycle and so
on. But The version of the ovulatory shift hypothesis
that steered so much debate over the last 10
years or 15 years almost. Um, IS a version
that assumes that female mating behavior changes in a
way that we could almost say there are two
kinds of female sexuality, one related to ovulation and
one related to sexual activity outside of the ovulatory
window, and that has been called the dual sexuality
hypothesis. And The original propositions that have been put
forward in that regard is that women only can
get pregnant during ovulation, whereas in our species, women
are sexually active. All around the ovulatory cycle and
also even when they are not ovulating, uh, and
so that there's a sexuality that is related to
adaptive problems of conception and whom they become pregnant
from, and there is a psychology related to sexual
activity when uh pregnancy risk is very low. So
what has been put forward in this regard is
that female mate choice has two goals, two components.
One is regarding direct benefits of mate choice, and
that is everything that directly helps the woman getting
pregnant and uh. Yeah, raising children, so there are
male preferences for things like male resources, male support,
male protection, also simply male fertility. And on the
other hand, there might be made preferences for indirect
benefits that include everything that the sire passes on
to the offspring and therefore benefits the offspring and
not directly the mother with her pregnancy. And these
indirect benefits would be anything that genetically is transmitted
from the father to the offspring. Now, the idea
here is that some Potential sires, some potential partners
might have genetic qualities that they can pass on
to offsprings that are only relevant during sexual activity
when conception is likely, and these have been termed
good genes in the literature, although in genetics, people
cringe a little bit when you call it good
genes because there is no intrinsic good or bad
value to genes. But you could translate it to
something like new, uh, like low mutational load, so
few rare events in the genome that disrupt anything
in the genome, you could translate it to, uh,
genetic endowments that fit very well the environment or
that are very compatible with the mother and all
of that together, we could call good genes. And
This idea which we often call the good genes
ovulatory cycle shift hypothesis in the literature is concerned
with whether women prefer different partners, different partner qualities
for sexual partners when conception is likely. Now, the
interesting bit of this hypothesis is that we are
a long-term binding species, so we tend to have
long-term relationships, not only meeting up for sexual activity
as some other species do, but forming long-term bonds.
And if you form a long-term bond, you have
a trade-off between these different kinds of qualities potentially.
You might be lucky and find somebody who Uh,
entails all these qualities, but you might face trade-offs,
and in this case, it might be that female
preferences for partners shift over her cycle and that
she would prefer a different partner when she's ovulating
and when she's in different phases of the menstrual
cycle or when she's pregnant or lactating or whatever,
so non-ovulating. And so a consequence of this idea
of the good genes ovulatory cycle shift hypothesis is
that within one long-term relationship, a woman might prefer
different partners, different uh um uh qualities, different traits
of sexual partners when she's ovulating. Than when she's
not, and if she is so unlucky and doesn't
find a perfect partner that entails everything, she might
even be motivated to um be sexually unfaithful during
ovulation and because of this very provocative uh. Yeah,
consequence of this hypothesis, uh, there's been a lot
of debate about around it.
So, uh, uh, that's the hypothesis and the several
different predictions that stem from it. But how have
you been, uh, you and your collaborators have been
evaluated, uh, have been evaluating it in your recent
studies, and, uh, I mean, what would you say
are perhaps the best study designs to properly test
the predictions that stem from the ovulatory shift hypothesis?
Yeah, it is a very complex hypothesis and that's
why study designs are quite important. And there have
been a huge amount of studies, dozens of studies
already around 2010, up to 2010, so this hypothesis
came up in the late 19990s. And then it
has been studied very intensely, and there have been
a whole array of studies that try to test
it, usually with asking women in which phase of
the menstrual cycle they are and then presenting them
different kinds of stimuli, faces, voices, videos with behaviors,
with dense behavior with competitive behavior, or, or simply
uh vignettes with descriptions of partners and so on.
Um, AND there have been studies that looked at
sexual interest that women have for their partner versus
potential partners outside of their relationships, which are then
based on self-reports basically. There were so many studies
on that, that there have been not one but
even two meta-analysis, both published in 2014, which came
to astonishingly quite different conclusions with regard to if
these ovulatory cycle shifts existed and that was around
the time when there was a lot of debate
in science in general and especially in psychology about
the replicability of findings. So this. Debates really started
with uh exactly the same point as the replication
crisis in psychology, so. Our lab was one of
several who said we need the sizes of studies
there and I actually, full disclosure was a huge
proponent of this whole ideas of uh cues to
uh genetic quality of uh ovulatory cycle shifts. I
was actually. Thinking or or or aiming for confirmatory
studies because I was theoretically completely convinced by this
hypothesis. So what, what we originally did, we started
off with a large online diary study where we
recruited both women with natural cycles, ovulating women. And
women uh on hormonal contraception, which could be used
as a quasi-control group because hormonal contraception basically, um,
Yeah, takes ovulation away and, and evens out the
hormone profile across the cycle. And we asked these
women more or less on a daily basis, several
things, but we Primarily asked them about their sexual
interest in a potential partner, in uh, if they
had a partner in their partner, uh also in
uh other men, and we asked a lot of
detailed questions that we're getting at these predictions of
the um good genes ovulatory cycle shift hypothesis. And
by far and large, we didn't find much in
that study with regard to the specific predictions. We
did find a lot with regard to shifts in
general sexual interest and everything that could be related
to that, so that women felt more attractive themselves
when they were ovulating, that they had more sexual
interest, that they had more masturbation interests, that they
had. Uh, MORE interest in being social and interacting
with men and so on that they perceived more
flirting attempts and so on. So there was a
lot going on which is in line with the
greater, uh, yeah, presence of a, of a sexual
mindset, so to speak, but the specific predictions by
the good genes ovulatory cycle shift hypothesis, um. Were
not very well confirmed and then we went on
to do other studies that included multiple testings of
women in the lab that included detailed hormonal measurements
based on saliva hormones and on urine tests. And
we presented them with all kinds of stimuli for
which it has been proposed that these preference shifts
should happen. These included. 3D scans, rotating 3D scans
of male bodies, which could entail information about masculinity
and all kinds of other traits that have been
proposed to be related to male-made quality, uh, and
also to genetic quality. We, uh, used voice samples
that, uh, should. Include information about how deep the
voice is, so about the fundamental frequency of the
voice, which has been very much discussed as an
indicator of uh male quality and especially also genetic
quality, and we also used videotapes, for example, um,
of uh male courtship behavior, flirting behavior. And We
had rather strong designs both in terms of sample
sizes, in terms of direct hormone measurements of longitudinal
assessments as opposed to cross-sectional assessments of uh female
fertility, but also in terms of statistical. Analysis and
also in terms of how carefully we tested our
analysis against potential uh um yeah, decisions that could
be debated, so different forms of determining uh ovulation
status, different forms of uh analyzing the hormones, different
uh forms of uh control variables, and so on.
And by far and large, we didn't find much
there as well, so it didn't seem to be
the case that preferences for voices, bodies, behaviors, and
so on. Shifted very much. Other labs at that
time uh studied other traits, for example, faces and
all the detail, and there wasn't much evidence there
either. The only thing we found in some studies,
it's not a huge effect, but it is a
fact that uh occurred in some of these analysis
is that women preferred all kinds of men more
when. Ovulating when around the ovulatory point in their
cycle, indicating that the general preference for men, these
were all heterosexual women by the way, but the
general preference for men was higher, but the rank
order of men was completely conserved, so that means
even the least attractive. Men as rated by these
women were still rated a little bit more attractive
when they were ovulating, so no preference shifts but
a general attraction effect.
Oh, OK, so, uh, but, but if there's really
this, um, shift in terms of their, uh, sexual,
in terms of their sexuality in the sense that,
as you said, they are more interested in just
all kinds of men, men in general, when, when
they're going through ovulation, uh, what would be, or,
or would there be an evolutionary rationale for that
in any way, um. I mean, and, and does
it link, uh because we tend to think from,
at least from an evolutionary perspective, uh, as women,
women, because, I mean, they have to bear the
costs of uh pregnancy and usually. Also, the costs
of child rearing and all of that, and I
mean they can only get pregnant once at a
time. I mean we tend to think of women
as being choosier than men. I mean, does that
relate In any way to this shift in terms
of their sexuality at all and and would it
in any way invalidate that idea that women are
really pickier than men or not or am I
or am I just perhaps mixing things here that
shouldn't be mixed.
I, I think these are two different aspects. So
there's a lot of studies on human-made choice that
show that women generally are pickier, but not necessarily,
it doesn't necessarily entail that anything about that changes
across the menstrual cycle. The phenomenon that is behind
all of this in a way is the idea
of estrus. Estras is the term that is used
in the animal literature, usually in the non-human, uh,
animal literature. Describing that in many species, the period
around ovulation is accompanied by clear behavioral changes. I
mean, the ovulatory cycle is a very evolutionary old
phenomenon. It is certainly changed uh uh shared by
all mammalian species, and in many species you see
that. Receptiveness, so the acceptance of copulation attempts by
females is limited to the time of ovulation. In
some species it's even more pronounced in the sense
that females actively. Uh, ACTIVELY, uh, Uh, approach copulation
attempts or advertise themselves, for example, in, in rats
and mice, there's this, uh, phenomenon of low doses
that they present their back basically, um, because they
are willing to copulate, um, uh, under these circumstances.
In some species, it's even called heat because it's
such an obvious phenomenon. And in some species you
even have changes in female attractiveness with ovulation, even
in our closer relatives in the primates in some.
You have, uh, sexual swellings even in our closest,
uh, relatives like uh chimpanzees and bonobos. In other
species like some, uh, baboon species, you have, uh,
vocal callings, uh, when female, uh, are ovulating and
some marmosets, you have clear chemical cues that they
smell differently to the males and all these phenomena
together are usually called estrus and the Idea that
was also discussed around the ovulatory cycle shift a
lot is, is there something resembling an asterisk in
human females as well, so could it be that.
Well, it's, it's certainly not as obvious as, for
example, in chimpanzees or bonobos where behavior changes dramatically
and also visible changes are dramatically there that even
humans can easily see them. But could it be
that some aspects of Eros are also there and
our species are probably evolutionarily conserved and Our findings
and also the findings of others including some of
these large scale replication attempts around this literature clearly
indicate that that is the case. Female sexual interest
seems to be the one robust thing that changes
with ovulation and that is highest during ovulation. So,
um, that makes a lot of evolut uh uh
evolutionary sense because. If evolution in the end in
sexual species is about reproduction, then when conception is
likely, sexual interest should be highest and sexual opportunities
uh should be seized that way. That makes a
lot of sense. The question is, is it related
to mate choice, and that is what you were
alluding to. On the other hand, that, yeah, I
mean the old mantra in evolutionary sciences is, um,
males compete, females choose, of course, there are many
exceptions to that rule, but female pickiness, female choosiness
is a widespread phenomenon. But humans are a species
that. Usually Uh, reproduces in pair bonds. So pair
bonding is a widespread human phenomenon as far as
we know it exists in all human societies and
it's probably the ancestral state as well. We don't
need necessarily to talk about lifelong monogamy. That is,
of course, a modern cultural invention that might. Have,
uh, a long religious history and cultural history, but
that humans form longer term bonds, especially around rep
reproduction is a widespread phenomenon. And the key moment
when mate choice is important is the long-term partner
choice. Now the ovulatory cycle shift hypothesis, the good
genes ovulatory cycle shift hypo hypothesis, moved that away
from that a little bit and said, yeah, well,
there might be long-term partner choice, but, Genetic sire
choice whom to copulate with when conception is most
likely might be different from that, and that is
at the core of this dual sexuality hypothesis. And
that is the part that has been put very
much in question by the recent literature, so, uh,
of course, women are choosy when it comes. Uh,
WITH regard to long-term sexual partners, it's probably also
are choosy when it comes to, uh, short term
mates with whom they might have affairs or one
night stands, but that doesn't need to be tied
to the ovulatory cycle or at least that, that
is a specific hypothesis that can be tested and
that has happened in the last. 10 years.
OK, great. It's very important to clarify that point.
So, and how about preferences for men's behaviors, like,
for example, competitive or courtship behaviors, because I imagine
that that would be an issue that is separate
from just their. Uh, REFERENCE, their made preferences in
terms of, uh, uh, having good genes or not,
not, not so good genes or other physical traits.
So are there, is there any shift in terms
of, uh, preference for these kinds of behaviors during
ovulation?
Well, the question is, what do these behaviors transmit
in terms of information, so what information is there
for the women to decode from these behaviors and.
Many predictions have been floating around in the literature.
The original good genes ovulatory cycle shift hypothesis has
discussed all kinds of male behaviors as indicators of
genetic quality as well that included some ideas about
uh male dense behavior indicating uh a well-built and
even symmetrical body and so on, so that a
well put together body. Is able to show better
dance moves, that was an idea that was around
there, but most of them really related to masculine
behavior that is probably related to testosterone and that
elicits uh intra-sexual competition or male male competition, so
confident uh appearance, um. Yeah, uh, daring behavior, risky
behavior, or maybe even, um, uh, um, direct approach
behavior and so on. And that is all related
to the same predictions, um, that, that, or, or
to the same ideas that are also behind, uh,
other, uh, made preference shifts that have been predicted
in the literature, namely that individuals with male individuals
with higher testosterone. Are preferred during ovulation because it
ties back in one way or another to genetic
quality, so either, High testosterone is directly linked to
higher genetic quality and that has often been linked
to it via the immunocompetence handicap hypothesis that testosterone
lowers uh immunocompetence and that therefore only genetically fit
individuals could allow that, that hypothesis has all kinds
of problems and has been. Uh, EVEN on a
theoretical ground when challenged a lot. And the other
idea is that only men with high genetic quality
are in such a position that they have competitive
advantages that they can allow themselves to show daring
behavior, competitive behavior. I don't know, even aggressive behavior
or, or, um. Even in the presence of other
men. It all boils down basically back to this
idea is testosterone related to genetic quality and are
testosterone linked traits, be it facial or bodily masculinity,
deep voices, or some parts of behavior, are these
indicators of genetic quality, because otherwise I mean women
might just like confident men because. They get things
done. They are good providers of resources. They might
prefer stronger or high status men because they are
better at providing protection and so on. So there
are a lot of testosterone linked traits that would
entail direct benefits that are not necessarily tied to
conception risk to the ovulatory phase of the cycle.
These kinds of Traits of qualities women should prefer.
Uh, AT any time, but not only at specific
parts of the cycle, but only if you link
these behaviors in one way or the other back
to genetic quality, the ovulatory cycle shift hypothesis even
makes theoretical sense. And this whole link between testosterone
and genetic quality is sounded pretty convincing around the
2000s, but uh it's probably not the strongest candidate
anymore. So if we would really be serious about
the good genes ovulatory cycle shift hypothesis, we should
actually move towards traits where we now, after 20
years, 25 years of genomic research since the human
genome was decoded, where we now know that these
are traits that are tightly linked to. Genetic quality
as it has been defined in the evolutionary literature,
so for example, mutation load, and that would rather
be traits like. Absence of psychopathologies, probably intelligence. Maybe
some other aspects of physical appearance, but especially traits
like intelligence or absence of psychop pathologies like schizophrenia,
autism, uh, um, epilepsy or so on where the
evidence is pretty strong that they are related to
mutational events. These traits have rarely been studied with
regard to links to cycle shifts, and if they
have been studied, they usually didn't show much of
an effect. So the absence, for example, of a
cycle shift for preferences for intelligence is actually also
something that doesn't sit very well with the good
genes ovulatory shift hypothesis.
Right, so I would like to ask you now
about some of the predictions that have been made
when it comes to changes in women's behaviors during
ovulation or even cues to fertility. So is there
any evidence to support the idea of an increase
in women's general attraction during evolution? I mean, I
do. Or do they appear more attractive to men
when they are ovulating or not?
Yeah, yeah, that was another part of ovulatory shifts
that has been discussed a lot. It's not necessarily
tied to the good genes ovulatory shift hypothesis, but
it is tied to this idea of an asterisk.
So if we look at Female chimpanzees or female
bonobos during ovulation, we see these rectal swellings that
are extremely visible and so the most direct idea
would be that hormones have a direct effect on
the female body that translates to a higher attractiveness
and it's certainly not as obvious as the. Primate
shifts because women simply don't have these kinds of
swellings and if anyone should be able to see
these changes if they happen, then it is males
of the same species, so us. But there has
been this idea that, yeah, well, there might be
leaky cues that are still there and showed a
little bit or there might be vestigial cues that
have been more relevant in the past and uh
are still perceivable now and so things like changes
in the female face have been studied, like coloration
of the female face. Symmetry of the breasts, uh,
changes in the voices, changes in the smell, changes
in the gait or in the uh dancing behavior
or, or movement behavior of women and so on.
Again, there have been some studies early on that
seem to show these effects, but they were still
of the kind that usually didn't have the strongest
designs and the stronger replications usually didn't find much.
So for example, if we take changes in facial
coloration, which would be a very obvious one because
we know that hormones that change across the ovulatory
cycle like estradiol have effects on the blood vessels
and could actually change facial coloring, so for example,
facial reddening. These changes are not immediately obvious. In
some studies, when you directly put photos of women
from different ovulatory faces next to each other, they
found some effects and others didn't find any effects,
and it doesn't seem to be obviously perceivable at
all. There was one study that directly tested for
the red coloration of the faces and found that
there was a tiny effect. But that effect was
so small that it was below the visible detection
level of the human eye. And that basically disqualifies
it as any kind of evolved signal or even
as a perceivable leaky cue and that brings us
to a very interesting point because sometimes these studies
try to squeeze out statistical significance in one way
or another, but for. Something to be evolutionarily relevant,
it should have a sizable effect so that even
in the long run across generations, it could make
an evolutionary difference. And so what we need really
is for these kinds of effects the smallest effect
size of interest. There are now statistical tests. That
you can test if an effect, even if you
find it statistically significant, is big enough to make
a difference, but for that you have to define,
and that's something you can only do theoretically. You
have to define how small an effect can be
to still make a difference. But if something is
not detectable by the human eye anymore, it will
certainly fall below this threshold of the smallest effect
size of interest and for red coloration in the
face. That is certainly the case. Now, this whole
literature also moved beyond that and thought, well, maybe,
uh, may may maybe let me add in something
that hasn't been studied a lot but that would
make for a very interesting and, and plausible cue
of ovulation is smell. So olfaction studies are rare
in humans because they are complicated to do. And
they are often not very promising because we are
not a very olfactory-driven species, so compared to a
lot of other species, including a lot of primates,
we are way, way more dependent on our visual
and auditory senses and not so much on our
olfactory senses, on our sense of smell. But it
would still be plausible that hormones change female scans
over the cycle so that males would be able
to perceive that. If that's relevant in everyday life
situations, it's a different thing because we have high
standards of body hygiene and uh we usually use
perfumes and uh other bits, but it could still
be that there are detectable changes there. Um, WHAT
we did in the last few years is we
did a big study on females across the ovulatory
cycle, including longitudinal hormonal measurements and including samples of
both their axillary and their vaginal smell. So we
had women wear basically cotton pads under their arms
and in their pubic region. Over a cycle and
we collected them and gave them male participants to
evaluate regarding the smell, regarding the intensity and the
pleasantness of the smell, but also directly regarding the
attractiveness of the smell and. By far and large
we found nothing, so there were no changes in
male ratings of these cotton pets, these smell samples,
but we also did gas chromatography analysis of the
chemical compositions of the smells to see if anything
changes with regard to the chemicals in the smell
across the cycle, because if there are some. LEFTOVER
products from physiological processes that end up as detectable
molecules in these samples, then they should be there
on these cotton pads and they should be analyzable
and even that didn't. YIELD any convincing results, so
there isn't even a chemical change that could potentially
be detected. So we can basically cross off chemical
cues as something to change over the ovulatory cycle
as well. Now if I might add to that
bigger part of the literature in humans is do
women present themselves differently because we are a species
that. Does not evaluate others simply based on their
physical or on the bodily uh um appearance, but
that also looks at how we present ourselves in
terms of clothing, in terms of grooming and all
these kinds of aspects. And there have been studies
in the literature that proposed that women dress differently,
for example, uh, wear more revealing clothes, show more
skin, wear more conventionally, uh, uh, attractive clothing, choose
different colors for their clothing, or for example, for
their makeup, and there was also this idea that
similarly to the sexual swellings and other primate species.
And pink should be the colors that we are
evolutionarily adapted to, to react to in the sexual
context. So people looked at red lips lipstick and
uh red uh nail polishing or red or pink
clothing and so on. There were some studies that
found these effects and, and discussed them as pretty
relevant, but then bigger replication studies came, including some
of ours and we, we, we published a paper,
Julia Stern and um Sabio Ostermann and I published
a paper a few years ago where we replicated
all kinds of ideas that have been proposed in
that regard in the literature in 5 studies. And
we basically found nothing at all. To the contrary,
some of the effects were in the opposite direction
that women apparently uh wore more sexy clothes, if
you want to put it that way, when they're
in the, when they were in the non-fertile phase
of the cycle. So by far and large we
again see a huge Null finding there and that
at least puts a big question mark to uh
a lot of ideas that have been proposed originally.
OK, so I, I mean, at this point in
time, what can we say about the possibility of
there being any cues to fertility in women during
ovulation? I mean, are there any cues at all
that have been supported by the scientific evidence?
Well, if there are any cues at all, there
are in the female behavior, and that is something
that we found in our online diary studies that
women have different behavioral tendencies when they are ovulating
and that might be rather directly linked to that
shift in sexual motivation. So the sexual desire effect
is there, it is pretty robust. And we found
that women It's another thing that we found very
robustly across several samples is that women perceive themselves
as more attractive. So women feel more attractive when
ovulating. It's not a general self-esteem effect, it's not
a general positive affectivity effect, so they are not
simply more happy when ovulating, but they specifically feel
more attractive when ovulating and. Our diary studies also
point to the fact that they are behaving differently
based on that. They are more social, they are
more flirty and all uh um uh things like
that. One big study that we did with my
former PhD student, uh, Lara Schleiffenbaum was a couple
diary study where we had 384 heterosexual romantic couples
that were in steady romantic relationships. And we had
both the men and the woman in that relationship
answer a couple diary, and we asked them questions
about themselves, but we also asked both of them
questions about their partner, how they perceived the partner
that day. We actually framed it a little bit
as a couple quiz that on a daily basis,
they should say how they feel and how the
other partner feels, and we had all kinds of
items. A lot of them were also regarding uh
sexual interest. And in that study, again, we showed
very clearly that women had higher sexual interest when
in the ovulating phase of their cycle, there was
even some tendencies that they initiated sexual contact more
or try to initiate sexual contact more. But the
funny thing was the male partners didn't seem to
notice any of that. So when you look at
how these men rated on the same day, how
much sexual interest they perceived uh from their partner,
these were usually even cohabiting couples, so they had
plenty of time to see something, uh, what was
going on in their partner. They didn't seem to
pick up on anything there. And I mean the.
Evolutionary psychological literature made more specific predictions with regard
that men should pick up this heightened sexual interest
in women and react to it not only by
sexual interest but also by, for example, be potentially
more jealous because if these women feel more attractive
and behave more attractive and behave more flirty and
more social and so on. And men really picked
up on that, then they might get more jealous
or they might be more interested in occupying the
time of that woman, which is sometimes called mate
retention or mate guarding behavior in the literature. And
we asked for these kinds of behaviors as well,
and there was no effect of the female cycle
status on these kinds of behaviors as well. So
it doesn't seem to be the case that men
really perceive something there and. So yes, women feel
differently, are differently motivated when ovulating, and might actually
show related behaviors, but if they are not even
translating to different behaviors in the male partners, then
it's very unlikely that they. Change behaviors and, and
other men that only briefly observe the women either.
Uh LET me just ask you, and this is
more of a theoretical question, but uh do you
think that if, for example, women uh behave differently,
I, I mean, they express in terms of their
behavior, more sexual interest or more sexual availability during
ovulation, uh, should we Interpret that as a cue
to fertility or as simply a cue to sexual
availability or sexual interest. I mean, do you think
that it would be important to establish such a
distinction or not, since it happens during ovulation?
Well, most directly it's an cue to sexual interest,
but I think it makes good adaptive sense that
it is coupled to fertility. So I think it
is our old evolutionary heritage that the same hormones
that Basically, uh, um, determine female reproductive functioning at
the same time regulate sexual interest, and there is
really good evidence all across the, uh, mammalian spectrum
and even in other species that these links exist
in other species, so that is really something that
we share with other species, uh, very obviously. And
that makes a lot of sense. Why should, uh,
I mean, sexual interest as sexuality has a lot
of functions in our species. We are a species
with a, an extended sexuality that achieves different things
with our sexual activity, but that sexually, sexual motivation
should be highest at the time when it serves
its most direct biological evolutionary function, namely potential conception.
Uh, MAKES perfect sense, and um I, I think
that's the key of the message here.
Mhm. OK, so when it comes to the evolution
of concealed ovulation as we have in human females,
I mean, and particularly since when we look at
our phylogenetically closest relatives like chimpanzees and bonobos, I
mean they have tras, I mean females from both
species have tras. So I mean what. Uh, Among
the different hypo hypotheses that people might have been
putting forth, uh, recently or, yeah, I, I mean,
not, not, not necessarily just recently, but that people
have been suggesting, uh, ever since we've been studying,
studying that topic. Uh, I, I mean, is there
any one of them that you think is has
most support in terms of explaining the evolution of
concealed ovulation in humans?
Yeah, that's a really complicated topic and one that
you really need to study phylogenetically, um, and it's,
it's really different, uh, difficult to, to tease, uh,
different hypotheses apart in that regard. But what I
often hear from my primatologist colleagues is that As
far as the evidence goes, the last common ancestors
of Homo and Pan, so of us and the
chimpanzees and bonobos, did actually not have advertised ovulation.
So it is not a question of why humans
lost science to ovulation, why. Ovulation got concealed in
the homo lineage, but it seems to be a
question of why there was selective pressure on advertised
ovulation in the palm line for the chimpanzees and
the bonobos, and that has probably to do with
their very promiscuous mating system. Now, I mean, there
are different explanations in the literature related to parental
investment and pair bonding that concealed ovulation basically. Is
an evolutionary route to secure long-term pair bonding by
basically making it less obvious when copulation leads to
conceptions for the male so that the male needs
to stick around with females for longer periods of
time to ensure. To reproduce at all and actually
there are phylogenetic analysis across the whole mammalian spectrum
that indicate that uh concealed ovulation often precedes the
evolution of pair bonding, which is rare in mammals
but exists in some species. Some other analysis point
towards reduction of infanticide as a very important aspect
of the evolution of concealed ovulation across primate species
because often males tend to kill offspring of other
males so that the women become available, uh, the
women, females become available for um. Um, Uh, FOR
copulation and for, for reproduction earlier. Um, AND there
might be some truth to the reduction of infanticide
hypothesis as well. There might be some aspects of
human concealed ovulation that is related to the complexity
of our social groups, of our social societies, because
concealed ovulation reduces. Intersexual competition both between uh males
and females in the species and if you want
to have large groups of, of unrelated collaborating individuals
as we have in humans and as is very
important for our um yeah, ability for culture and,
and um division of labor and so on which
are huge, huge assets in human evolution. Then concealed
uh concealed ovulation is certainly an asset. Um, IT
is really difficult to completely distinguish between all these
hypotheses and I'm not sure if the current data,
uh, completely allows that and maybe all of them,
uh, uh, are true to some degree, but my
perspective is that it's not so much a puzzle
why Ovulation is concealed in humans, but more a
question of why other species have so clearly advertised
ovulation. And that, that would be evolution towards signals
of fertility where there's an active evolutionary process to
make uh ovulation more visible to other members of
the species. What is even more discussed is if
there are indirect cues of lost estros that still
indicate ovulation and so on, but that would usually
be something like the reddening of the face or
the smell, especially of the vaginal area or so
on, and. Even those kinds of cues don't really
seem to exist in humans, at least there's no
strong convincing evidence, and so our baseline null hypothesis
uh should just be that there simply are no
signs of or even cues of ovulation.
Mhm. OK, so, uh, uh, I, I have 3
more questions. Two of them are more general, and
the last one will be more about, uh, uh,
more of a theoretical question regarding evolutionary psychology more
broadly. But at, at this point in time, what
can we tell about the cycle shift theories then?
I mean, uh what can we tell as to
whether We should still take some, at least some
of the predictions predictions seriously, scientifically, and to what
extent they have been supported or not by the
most rigorous evidence that we have.
By far and large, so I, I still think
it's very interesting to study these hormones across the
cycle because these hormones definitely act in the whole
body and they also act on the brain and
It is still extremely plausible that something about the
psychology changes across the cycle as well, not only
the reproductive functioning and some other physiological aspects, and
I think the general sexual desire, sexual motivation aspect
is rather well proven. And I regard changes in
self-perceived attractiveness and some behavioral tendencies that women show
uh across the cycle basically as a downstream effect
of that. And that I'm pretty sure about. Then,
then there are other bits that have been tied
to the ovulatory cycle that I think are also
interesting that are not that well supported, but have
reasonable support and are certainly interesting to study further.
For example, James Roney uh has this hypothesis that
during the second half of the ovulatory cycle, during
the luteal phase. Um, UNDER the influence of progesterone,
uh, appetite changes, and women tend to eat more
and that, that is also an adaptive, um, mechanism
that potentially prepares for pregnancy or at least for
somatic investment in life history terms. Uh, I find
that a rather interesting hypothesis in some of our
studies, we have some evidence for that as well.
I don't regard it as, as well supported as
a Uh, sexual preference, uh, sexual motivation shift. But
all these way more specific hypotheses. They were super
interesting and they were super compelling even from a
theoretical perspective, but my understanding of the literature is
that by now they are. Have been so often
disproven that it's not very likely that they exist.
I'm not saying that it can't be that they
exist at all. Some things haven't been tested at
all. Some things haven't been tested very well. So
if people want to, I am very open to
see. New studies on this topic and if people
can show that on very specific aspects there are
still preference shifts or there are still uh shifts
in specific aspects of sexual motivation that really point
towards uh sexual attraction to non-primary partner, uh, partners
when ovulating also on. I'm still open to that,
but. As the literature stands right now, my. Basic
tenet would be to say these effects are not
there and it requires really strong good evidence to
show them. That, that is my current take on
the literature.
OK, so because the ovulatory shift hypothesis, or at
least part of it, as we've already talked about
here, is based on the idea or the hypothesis
of good gene sexual selection in humans, what about
that? Hypothesis specifically, I mean, at this point in
time, what, um, how do you interpret or what,
what do you have to say about the general
evidence that we have for sexual selection in humans
being based at least in part, of course, on
good genes.
So from an evolutionary genetic perspective based on the
available molecular genetic and genomic evidence, it seems to
be that quite a few human traits are under
mutation selection balance, meaning mutations occur, mutations increase the
variance in traits, and selection is part of the
mechanism that. Uh Limits that this variation doesn't increase
over time more and more. So there is pretty
direct molecular genetic evidence that for all kinds of
human traits, uh, mutation selection balance seems to operate
to some degree and uh. The question is what
are the mechanisms here? This has partly been taken
as evidence that sexual selection plays a role here,
but it could simply be that if mutations occur
that are too far outside of. The standard human
range that, that simply leads to uh uh uh
um lethal birth, so basically to a stillbirth or
that, that leads to infertility or that, that leads
to uh a shortened lifespan and so on, and
then that alone. Is what selects uh against this
variants, but it could very well be that there's
sexual selection for these traits as well, but curiously
enough, it seems to encompass all kinds of human
traits, not only the ones that are mostly discussed
in the evolutionary literature as indicators of uh mate
quality or or even uh genetic quality. Um And
the other bit is that the question is in
what range is a trait neutral in that regard
and at which point is it really selected against
and I think what is happening with the whole
attractiveness literature that of course has been influenced a
lot by uh evolutionary psychology. Is that we are
focusing on differences between individuals that are in a
range where they don't really matter. So if we
have our standard student sample, which are still our
white mice in psychology in terms of that it
is the most studied population, it might be that
in a standard student sample, phenotypic differences that might
reflect. Uh, GENETIC variation are in a range where
Mutational load, mutational uh incidence don't really matter. So
it could be that only at the extremes of
the distribution when we are really talking about limiting
uh mutations that uh uh lead to uh uh
limited capabilities or so on. um. That there are
the differences are also so visible to other individuals
that uh in one way or another, they uh
affect made choice decisions. Um, THERE is an interesting
uh hypothesis in the attractiveness literature called the uh
overgeneralization hypothesis, and that is basically that. We are
adapted to pick up certain cues and we use
them to distinguish in our judgments of attractiveness and
of mate quality, but When the stimulus material that
we see is very limited in the range of
these traits, then we try to make distinctions where
these distinctions don't really have any informational value. And
so we might even be able to pick up.
Minuscule differences in skin quality or face symmetry or
uh averageness of the face, and we might use
that for our attractiveness judgments and same with all
other forms of attractiveness, but. These cues only matter
in the very extremes, and these extremes we usually
don't even see in our samples. So, um, by
far and large, I still think that. Mutations contribute
a lot to genetic variants in humans and that
a lot of traits in humans are under mutation
selection balance, but I'm doubtful that in the samples
we usually study something like made preferences or made
decisions that these differences really point to differences in
genetic quality.
Uh, OK, so, uh, before I ask you my
last question, there's something that you mentioned there that
I really want to ask you a little bit
more about. So, uh, do you think that perhaps,
uh, in evolutionary psychology specifically, we could talk about
psychology more broadly, but do you think that The
fact that there are still many studies where the
sample of people are basically used are basically university
students that we are not looking, we, and by
we I mean people in Uh, evolutionary psychology are
not looking at diverse enough samples of people to
really study some of these phenomena as being part
of our evolved psychology.
Oh definitely, definitely. I mean, I don't think it
is worthless to study convenient sample, but if we
find something we should show that it holds more
broadly. So my whole career, I always tried to
at least recruit samples from the general population in
studies where I could afford it in one way
or another and not only the student samples that
come cheap because we can give them uh course
credit for participation. Um, BUT of course, even if
I find something in a general population like Germany
or any other country, uh, doesn't mean that I
can. Immediately generalize to the whole human species, and
I think, uh, anthropological work is invaluable in that
regard and that we should definitely, if we propose
that something is a universal human adaptation or as
part of the universal adaptive design of humans, we
definitely need to show that it uh exists in
other samples. Um. And that is especially true for
um this whole um ovulatory literature as well because
if you look to natural fertility populations like small
scale uh societies that anthropologists usually study. Then you
see that women usually have few ovulatory cycles during
their adult life because they tend to be pregnant
or lactating or in some cases malnourished and uh
therefore not healthy uh and therefore uh uh not
ovulating so. It is actually a viable hypothesis to
say in our environment of evolutionary adaptiveness. Ovulatory cycles
didn't happen very often during a female lifespan, so
that these very specific effects that ovulation should have
these very specific conditions where um behavior then would
have to make a difference in terms of fitness
that they simply didn't occur often enough, so. Yes,
I think the fact that basically all of the
uh ovulatory shift literature has been studied in the
typical Western educated, industrialized, rich and democratic societies, the
weird societies, uh is a big limitation in that
regard.
Mhm. Yeah, yeah, and if I may, uh, I
mean, of course, anthropological, the anthropological literature is very
important, and I think that collaboration with anthropologists more
generally, but I think that in this case, for
example, when it comes to ovulation, taking into account
the, those specific circumstances where Where women might be
pregnant more of the time or might suffer from
malnutrition. I think that in those cases specifically, it's
very important for us to also study the impact
or the influence of ecological factors and perhaps look
into, look into human behavioral ecology, for example.
That's where um behavioral endocrinology becomes very interesting because
I mean what hormones generally do is keep the
body in balance and keep the body in balance
in terms of the challenges that we are experiencing
from our surroundings. So I often compare. Uh, HORMONES
to emotions and that they put us in a
different adaptive mode that helps us to face the
challenges that we are facing right now more effectively
with the end result to keep the body. Imbalance
and we know that steroid hormones and ovulatory cycles
are very responsive to, for example, physical condition of
the body, health status, uh, nutrition status, uh, body
mass index, so basically caloric status, and This is
very important because the body has to decide, is
it a good idea to reproduce right now or
would it increase my fitness if I postpone reproduction
to a later point in time, and that is
why there is a phenomenon of amenorrhea, which is
basically the. Stopping of the ovulatory cycle in response
to these kinds of conditions, and that tells us
that the ovulatory cycle is adaptively attuned in a
very, Fine manner to these kinds of challenges, so
there is a lot of. Evolutionarily interesting things going
on with the menstrual cycle, but probably not everything
that has ever been proposed in the literature.
Right. So to get into my final question then,
um, how do you look at uh the general
role of falsification in evolutionary psychology? I mean, uh,
uh, and I'm also asking you this because Sometimes,
uh, I might worry that perhaps at least when
it comes to certain hypotheses like the evolutory shift
hypothesis that we've explored here today, maybe, uh, Uh,
some, I, I, I don't want to say all,
but at least some evolutionary psychologists and perhaps the
ones that are more invested in this hypothesis specifically
and other hypotheses as well, um, perhaps they, they
do not take falsification as seriously as they should.
And I, I mean, if I may say so,
sometimes perhaps there's there's a risk or they're putting
themselves at risk of really being accused and there
being some, at least some grain of truth to
those kinds of accusation of accusations of promoting um
so-called uh. Uh, I mean, just so, uh, stories
are just so storytelling, storytelling when it comes to,
uh, hypothesis developed by evolutionary psychologists. I mean, uh,
do you agree with that and what do you
think about this
more broadly? Well, I think that the whole development
of the ovulatory cycle uh literature is actually something
that helped the field by showing that it is
a falsifiable field. I mean, I still regard myself
and I always have regard myself as an evolutionary
psychologist and I have no doubt about the theory
of evolution and I have no doubt that the
theory of evolution is probably the most important unifying
theory for the whole life sciences including psychology and
psychology is a field that in general lacks theoretical
support and It used to have a lot of
theories that didn't really hold up like psychoanalysis, and
now it is often in a theoretical void or
theories are just proposed on a fly based on
uh everyday life intuitions or so on, and I
think that it is a huge problem of psychology
in general at the moment. So I think it
is really important to take evolutionary theory. Serious and
to use it for hypothesis generation in psychology, but
that doesn't mean that every hypothesis that is in
line with evolutionary thinking. Has to be right and
hypotheses have to be translated into testable predictions. We
have to develop paradigms to make these predictions testable
and then we should test them from all kinds
of angles and of course. Individual negative studies don't
disprove a prediction, but if enough evidence amounts at
some point, we should say this prediction is highly
unlikely and we should probably move on. And as
I observe it, the field of evolutionary psychology mostly
has moved on from the evolutionary, uh, from, from
the ovulatory shift hypothesis. And I think it's a
good thing to show. That this is an example
of falsifiable evolutionary psychology. I mean, falsification basically entails
that you are precise enough in terms of your
predictions, your methods, your operationalization of variables, and so
on, that you can run empirical tests that can
be supportive or not supportive of the prediction, and
that is really what has happened here, I mean.
The whole debate has sparked so much uh conversations
about how to really conceptualize ovulation. Do you use
windows? Do you use continuous measurements? It has sparked
a lot of debate about measurement of hormones. Can
you really measure steroid hormones well from saliva samples?
Do you need other media? Um, Is it really
sufficient if you use standard immuno essays or do
you uh use something like mass spectrometry, which we
have been using in our studies and so on.
So there has been a lot of method development,
design development around this debate, and I think that
was good and healthy for evolutionary psychology. And of
course a hypothesis can never be completely disproven, but
we are at a point. Where it looks in
a way that at least some of these more
complex hypotheses are unlike me and that puts out
a nice challenge to people who still want to
stick to these hypotheses to come forward with better
designs, better tests, better samples, and so on, and
I'm completely open to change my mind again, as
I've done before, uh, when the evidence points in
a different direction, and that is healthy for the
field and it doesn't mean that. Broad ideas of
sexual selection or of uh parental investment theory or
of uh made choice or so are wrong as
well because it is only one specific hypothesis and
some very specific predictions that don't seem to be
that likely anymore and I mean this. Old accusation
of just so storytelling that dates back to uh
Gould and Levantin was made at a time when
the empirical literature was scarce and thin and didn't.
Uh, STAND on, on, on very solid ground, and
I think that has changed tremendously. And I don't
think we are completely there. There's still quite a
bit of weak research in evolutionary psychology, and I
think it is still worthwhile to tidy that up
and to move on to more direct evidence, for
example, not only talking about good genes, but really
looking at genomic evidence for mutation load and uh
similar things. But, um, I think we are, are
on a good path there and this was an
important step in that direction. And by the way,
just soul storytelling is not limited to evolutionary psychology.
There's a lot of just soul storytelling and standard
psychology, social psychology, developmental psychology, and so on as
well, um, where These kinds of accusations haven't really
sparked that much of development.
Mhm. Great. So, uh, Doctor Pinke, would you like
to tell people where they can find your work
on the internet?
Yeah, well, they can just Google me. I think
I'm easily Googleable. Um, uh, MY homepage is Laspeel.u
but you can also find me at the University
of Gotting Psychology department. Uh, OTHERWISE, I'm on all
kinds of standard, uh, social networks, Blue Sky, LinkedIn,
uh, X, whatever. So, if you want to get
in touch, please get in touch.
OK, great. So thank you so much for taking
the time to come on the show. It's been
a fascinating conversation.
Thank you very much. It was a pleasure.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltonin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Eddin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel Pan Scortez
or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith,
and Wiseman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Ebert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.